Guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich heiße Dr. Seifet in Östensöy. Ich bin der Dienstabendarzt in dieser Stelle.
Und heute werde ich das Annemnisgespräch mit Ihnen durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja. In dieser Stelle, was bedeutet in dieser Stelle?
Wir sind Ihnen notfallisch aufnahme, deswegen habe ich das gesagt.
Ja, auf der Station, nicht auf dieser Stelle.
Okay, in dieser Stelle ist es besser.
In dieser Stelle ist es türkisch übersetzt, es gibt es nicht im Deutschen.
Okay, ja, dann ist es dann mal auf dieser Station.
Oder einfach hier sagen, hier geht auch.
Ich bin hier der Aufnehmende.
Hier geht auch, hier ja.
Schön, karschel, tütje, burda, es ist hier, hier geht, aber in dieser Stelle geht nicht.
Falsch, hier oder auf der Station, auf dieser Station?
Okay, dann, einfach, dann.
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiß Ludwig Zacker.
Ludwig Zacker.
Könnt ihr langsam büsten, Ihren Vor- und Nachnäumen bitte?
Ludwig, L-U-D-W-I, Gustav, Zacker, mit Zeppelin, Z-Z also, A-C-K-E, Zacker.
C-K-E, Zacker.
Wie alt sind Sie in Herzacke?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
30 Jahre alt? Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 10. Mai 1994.
490. Wie groß sind Sie, Herzacker?
1,80 Meter.
1,86 Meter. Wie viele wiegen Sie?
Wie viele geht nicht? Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Herzacker?
Ich wiege 100 Kilo.
Und, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Notfallsanitäter.
Okay, in diesem Fall, wir sind Kollege, das heißt ja.
Sind Sie Notfallsanitäter? Ich dachte, Sie sind Arzt.
Ich bin Arzt, aber wir arbeiten in den Gesundheitsbereich, deswegen habe ich das gesagt.
Ah ja, danke, ja, das stimmt, da haben Sie recht.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, wie heißt Ihr Hausarztin oder Hausarzt?
Ich habe keinen Hausarzt.
Oh mein Gott, aber das ist ein wichtiges Stress.
Könnten Sie sobald eine Anmeldung an Hausarzt machen?
Nein, das geht nicht. Anmeldung an Hausarzt machen gibt es nicht im Deutschen.
Könnten Sie sich bitte einen Hausarzt suchen?
Ich habe das nicht verstanden, aber okay.
Denen, wir brauchen manchmal ein paar Informationen,
und wir können diese Informationen von Ihren Hausarzt oder Hausarztin bekommen.
Deswegen ist es wichtig.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Sake, was ist Ihre Hauptbeschwerde?
Sake, ich heiße nicht Sake, ich heiße Zake.
Zake.
Zake, nicht Sake.
Okay Herr Sake, was führt Sie zu uns, was ist Ihre Hauptbeschwerde?
Was ist Ihre Hauptbeschwerde, haben Sie gesagt, nicht sind Beschwerden oder Beschwerde?
Beschwerde oder Beschwerde.
Ja, sehr gut. Dann ist alles wichtig.
Also es ist so, dass ich, ja, ich habe so starke Oberbauchschmerzen.
Oberbauchschmerzen.
Okay, wann dieser Schmerzen angefangen?
Bitte?
Wann sind diese Schmerzen angefangen?
Nein. Wann sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten,
oder wann haben die Schmerzen angefangen?
Okay, dann wann haben die Schmerzen angefangen?
Die Schmerzen haben angefangen ungefähr vor vier Tagen.
Ja, vier Tage.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und könnten Sie auf eines von eins bis zehn Ihre Schmerzen einschätzen?
Ein ist leichteste und so sehen ist die stärkste Schmerze.
Ist die stärkste Schmerzen, geht gar nicht.
Ist und Schmerzen ist falsch. Schmerzen ist Mehrzahl.
Ist ist Einzahl.
Wir müssen etwas anders sagen.
Also am Anfang war gut, also auf einer Schmerzskale von eins bis zehn,
wenn eins leichte und zehn starke Schmerzen sind.
Oder wenn eins leichte Schmerzen, zehn starke Schmerzen bedeutet.
So kann man das auch sagen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, dass sie ungefähr bei acht sind,
wenn ich die Schmerzen habe.
Okay, herz gebrauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel oder könnten Sie ertragen?
Es kommt und geht.
Jetzt gerade habe ich zum Beispiel keine Schmerzen.
Okay, dann ich konnte in diesem Fall das Annämmnisgespräch beenden.
Fortschüren.
Danke schön.
Und könnten Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ist es dunkel, kolikartig oder vorhand rückend?
Was heißt denn kolikartig? Ich weiß gar nicht, was kolikartig bedeutet.
Ich meine, wenn es ist krampfartig oder?
Wenn es ist krampfartig, geht nicht.
Wenn es krampfartig ist.
Ich muss nicht sprechen.
Sorry. Also ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie ich das sagen soll.
Also meine Schmerzen, wenn die da sind, tut es sehr stark weh.
Und dann ist es wieder weg und dann kommt es wieder.
Das kann ich nicht vorher sehen, wann die kommen und wann die gehen.
Und das sind dann so stechende Schmerzen.
Okay, wie lange gedauert ist es weg und gehe ich periode?
Bitte?
Wie lange gedauert eine Schmerzenperiode?
Wie oft?
Einmal im...
Nein, nein, nein. Was haben Sie vorher gesagt?
Das erste, was Sie gesagt haben.
Wie lange gedauert dieses Schmerzenperiode?
Geht und kommt, haben Sie gesagt.
Geht und kommt periode.
Geht und kommt.
Das geht nicht. Nein, nein, nein.
Das geht nicht.
Wie lange dauert der Schmerz an?
Ja?
Und das andere geht und kommt, dieser Satz war falsch, dramatikalisch falsch.
Am besten fragen, wie lange dauert der Schmerz an, wenn der Schmerz kommt?
Ganz einfach.
Das wollten Sie wissen, oder?
Ja, genau.
Aber das kann ich Ihnen nicht genau sagen.
Manchmal dauert das eine Minute an, manchmal dauert das zehn Minuten an.
Zum Beispiel vor vier Tagen, als das angesangen hat, habe ich ein heißes Bad genommen,
weil ich dachte, das tut vielleicht gut.
Dann habe ich mich ins Bad gelegt, habe so drei Stunden im Bad gelegen
und das hat mir gut getan.
Und dann waren die Schmerzen weg.
Okay, ja.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Ja.
Das fängt ganz, ja, ich kann gar nicht sagen.
Unter meinem Rippen in der Mitte fängt es an, da tut es weh
und dann strahlt es in mein Rücken aus.
Ich verstehe.
Sie müssen sagen, ich verstehe.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie irgendwelche andere Symptome, zum Beispiel Fieber, Übelkeit, Erbrechen?
Nein, also Übelkeit errechne ich nicht.
Fieber auch nicht.
Ich habe nur diese Schmerzen, die kommen und gehen.
Wann fangen diese Schmerzen zum Beispiel nach dem Essen,
oder gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöse?
Wann die Schmerzen anfangen, ob die Mahlzeiten abhängig sind,
meinen Sie, ob das zum Beispiel nach dem Essen auftritt und verstehe.
Darauf habe ich nicht geachtet, weiß, kann ich nicht sagen, weiß ich nicht.
Außer dem gibt es das Gefühl.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, letztens habe ich, hat meine Kollegin mir
Weintrauben geschenkt, ich habe die Weintrauben gegessen
und eine halbe Stunde später hatte ich wieder ganz schlake Schmerzen.
Nein, ich sage, ich habe es.
Sie haben keine Übelkeit, keine Fieber, Sie haben nicht Erbrechen.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Außer dem haben Sie Stärfrost, Nachtschweiß.
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie Apotheosogenomen.
Nein, weder noch.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Wie meinen Sie beim Stuhlgang? Stuhlgang funktioniert eigentlich ganz normal.
Ganz normal, es gibt keine krankhaftige Situation, zum Beispiel Blut, Schleim oder andere.
Was meinen Sie? Also Blut habe ich nicht gesehen, Schleim habe ich nicht gesehen.
Was wollen Sie noch wissen?
Wie ist die Konsistenz?
Normal.
Was wollen Sie noch wissen?
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Einmal am Tag.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Durchschlafen oder Einschlafen?
Wenn ich keine Schmerzen habe, schlafe ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Haben Sie vorher auf der Hand wegen Schmerzen?
Noch mal sagen Sie das bitte noch mal.
Haben Sie wegen Schmerzen in der Nacht aufzustehen?
Haben Sie aufstehen, geht das?
Geht dieser Satz grammatikalisch, eine Frage.
Haben Sie aufstehen?
Nein, sind Sie wegen den Schmerzen aufgestanden?
Sagen Sie es bitte noch mal.
Sind Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen aufgestanden?
Nein, also nein, in der Nacht aus dem Schlaf bin ich nicht wach geworden.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Herz?
Zum Beispiel Herzgruppen, Herzstapen und Herzstapen.
Nein, ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Müdigkeit?
Müdigkeit? Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe nur die Schmerzen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Veränderungen auf Ihrem Haut bemerkt?
Was für Hautveränderungen meinen Sie?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Jetzt gehe ich hier vor Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Kronsche vor Erkrankungen?
Ich habe eigentlich keine Erkrankungen, keine Vorerkrankungen.
Sind Sie ganz gesund in diesem Fall?
Bitte?
Nein, eigentlich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Voroperation?
Nein, ich bin auch nicht operiert worden.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas allergisch?
Allergien habe ich nicht.
Ich habe mich nicht verabredet.
Ich habe andere Allergien.
Noch mal?
Gibt es sonst andere Allergie auch?
Andere Allergie? Hab ich nicht, nein.
Okay. Darf ich fragen, wie äußert dieses Allergie?
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie? Äußert gehört immer sich dazu.
Okay. Wie äußert sich dieses Allergie?
Ich kriege Ausschlag am ganzen Körper, auch mein Hals wird dick.
Hautausschlag oder Autausschlag?
Ja, Hautausschlag und Halsschwellung.
Waren Sie schon einmal im Notfallstelle wegen dieses Allergie?
Notfallstelle, was ist nur Notfallstelle?
Notfallaufnahme.
Notaufnahme, Notfallaufnahme gibt es nicht. Bitte nicht sagen. Notaufnahme.
Es gibt nur eine Notaufnahme. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich nehme das ja nicht. Ich weiß ja, dass ich Allergie bin, deswegen nehme ich das gar nicht.
Okay, in dieser Phase nutzen Sie gegen dieses Allergie kein Medikament.
Nein.
Rauchen Sie Herzöke?
Nein. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ähm, ja schon, wenn ich mich mal mit Freunden treffe.
Wie oft zum Beispiel einmal pro Woche oder pro Tag?
Nein, einmal im Monat vielleicht.
Einmal im Monat und einmal. Was trinken Sie?
Was ich trinke? Alkohol?
Wein, Bier oder...
Ach, weiß ich nicht, das, was wir kriegen. Meistens Bier.
Meistens Bier.
Und wie viele trinken Sie beim...
Das weiß ich nicht, das keine Ahnung.
Kommt drauf an. 2 bis 3 vielleicht.
Gut, 2 bis 3 vielleicht.
Okay.
Ihr habt eine Routemessgefrage und bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Und haben Sie irgendeine Wartekontakte mit Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Oh.
Ähm, ich verstehe.
Jetzt gehe ich Ihre Familien am Leben, sind Ihre Eltern am Leben?
Ja, bitte.
Sind Ihre Eltern am Leben?
Ja, meine Eltern sind beide noch am Leben.
Sind Sie gesund oder haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist etwas übergewichtig, so wie ich.
Er hat ein Bluthochbruch, mein Vater.
Konntest du nicht hören? Könntest du wiederhören?
Ich muss mal kurz aufstehen.
Mein Vater hat einen Renn. Mein Vater ist genauso dick wie ich.
Und hat Bluthochbruch.
Okay, Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist gesund.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, die ist zwei Jahre jünger als ich, die ist auch gesund.
Okay.
Hatte, sind Sie verheiratet?
Mhm.
Ich bin verheiratet und habe vier Kinder.
Das ist sehr gut. Sie haben vier Kinder.
Mhm.
Sie mögen die Kinder so viel.
Bitte?
Sie mögen die Kinder zu viel nicht, sondern die mögen Kinder sehr, sagt man.
Nicht zu viel.
Okay, sie mögen die Kinder sehr.
Ja, ich mag Kinder sehr.
Sie sind Notfallmediziner, Notfall-Santerien.
Mhm.
Bitte?
Und haben Sie Stress beim Arbeit?
Ja, ich habe Stress auf der Arbeit.
Stress auf der Arbeit, ne?
Stress auf der Arbeit.
Hab ich Stress auf der Arbeit?
Eigentlich nicht. Nein.
Okay.
In der letzten Seite haben Sie im Ausland gewesen?
Noch mal, bitte? Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
In der letzten Seite sind Sie im Ausland gewesen?
Mhm.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Wäre schön, aber es ist egal. Nein, war ich nicht.
Okay.
Sind Sie vorgeimpft?
Ja, ich bin geimpft. Sie meinen Covid, ne?
Ja, auch gut.
Ja, bin ich geimpft.
Okay.
Klar, ich habe alle benötigte Fragen gestellt.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Alle benötigten Fragen, nicht benötigten.
Alle benötigen Fragen.
Oder alle wichtigen Fragen, ob benötigten Fragen.
Ich meine required.
Ja, aber nicht benötigten, sondern alle nötigen Fragen gestellt.
Okay. Dann, alle nötigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich will nur wissen,
Ich will nur wissen, was ich habe.
Ich will mich heute mit meinen Freunden treffen.
Es wäre schön, wenn es nicht wichtig ist, dass ich wieder nach Hause gehen könnte.
Es ist ein bisschen früh für Ihre Situation bewerten und etwas zu sagen deutlich.
Erst müssen wir Sie Köpfe untersuchen.
Danach werden wir ein paar Labor untersuchen.
Wir können auch ein paar andere Massnahmen dufführen.
Danach werden wir mehr dort nicht sprechen und eine Entscheidung treffen.
Ich denke.
Okay, alles klar?
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie das im Mehrwert und wir werden die Massnahmen dufführen.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe die Strahlen, die Schmerzen, irgendwo hin aus.
Hat er ja schon gefragt, die Strahlen in dem Rückenhaus, habe ich gesagt.
Verspülen Sie die Schmerzen im Ganzen Oberbau?
Ja, gute Frage.
Was meine ich, die Schmerzen im Ganzen?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl im Ganzen Oberbau.
Ich kann gar nicht sagen rechts oder links, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay.
Haben Sie hellen Stuhl oder dunkles Wasserlassen bemerkt?
Ja, der Stuhlgang ist, warten Sie mal,
wann war denn das vor ein paar Tagen?
Das war vor vier Tagen, wo ich das Bad genommen habe.
Ich habe ein heißes Bad genommen, vier Stunden.
Da war mein Stuhlgang ganz, ganz hell.
Okay, dann nochmal normal geworden.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, das ist wieder etwas normaler.
Okay, und über RIN, über Wasserlassen, was können Sie machen?
Da ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Den dunkles Wasserlassen nicht.
Dankeschön.
Dunkles Wasserlassen.
Ob der Urin-Buckel war, meine Sie, nein, das bin ich aufgefallen.
Okay.
Hatten Sie früher endlich beischwerten?
Nein.
Erst mal.
Darf ich noch fragen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, zwei Fragen danach.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Gib es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich habe das neu,
es ist erst seit vier Tagen,
ich habe die Wärme gut getan, als ich das warme Bad genommen habe.
Aber es hält ja auch nicht immer sehr lange an.
Es hält ja immer nur maximal zehn Minuten an.
Das heißt, ich muss nur noch nicht mal eine Schmerz-Tablette einnehmen.
Nur jetzt ist es so, dass es jetzt sehr lange anhält.
Deswegen bin ich, hat es heute sehr lange angehalten.
Deswegen bin ich auch in die Notaufnahme gekommen.
Okay, und haben Sie eine gelbliche Verfarbung der Augen bemerkt
oder Ihre Kollegen?
Ich habe nicht genau darauf geachtet, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so gelb, dass es mir aufgefallen wäre.
Okay, danke.
Noch andere Fragen?
Obayan, jetzt hat er jetzt Spoilern gemacht.
Ja, zwei Fragen, Herr Cam.
Obayan, er wurde so noch,
dass er jetzt Spoilern gemacht hat.
Er hat eigentlich schon alles gebraucht.
Er hat nur die Stuhlfarbe, glaube ich, nicht erwähnt.
Ja, die Stuhl ist dunkel.
Genau, ich habe nicht dunkle Urin, aber der Stuhlgang war vor vier Tagen mal sehr hell.
Hab ich ja gesagt, ne?
Sind Ihre Schmerzen mit der Zeit verändert?
Haben Sie sich verschlechtert oder verbessert?
Meine Schmerzen?
Also, ich hatte vor vier Tagen diese Schmerzen,
dann hatte ich zwei Tage nichts.
Und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, dass es, wie soll ich es sagen,
dass es häufiger kommt.
Häufiger.
Die Stärke ist es nicht stärker geworden, aber es ist häufiger geworden.
Es kommt häufiger.
Die Frequenz hat sich geändert.
Ja, Intensität ist...
Die Intensität ist gleich, aber wenn es länger anhält, tut es wirklich sehr weh.
Die Intensität war vor vier Tagen auch bei acht.
Und jetzt heute war es auch bei acht.
Ich habe heute etwas gegessen.
Und nach dem Essen hatte ich erst mal keinen Beschwerden.
Aber dann, nach einer halben Stunde, drei Viertelstunde,
dann habe ich den ganzen Anfang angefangen.
Danke schön.
Könnten wir erstens anfangen, Herr Herr?
Bitte schön, Siefetin.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarsten.
Hallo.
Hallo, ich habe einen neuen Patient.
Und ich würde gerne dieses Patient berichten.
Ich würde gerne diesen Patienten vorstellen.
Ich würde gerne diesen Patienten vorstellen, oder ich würde gerne über diesen Patienten sprechen.
Nein. Ich würde gerne diesen Patienten vorstellen oder ich würde gerne über diesen Patienten sprechen.
Bin ich dann über?
Geht auch, geht auch, geht auch. Ich würde gerne über diesen Patienten berichten, geht auch.
Es geht um Ludwig Zecke. Er ist ein 30-jähriger Patient. Er ist 1,80 Meter groß und er ist 100 kg.
Wer? Muss man sagen. Er wiegt 100 kg oder er ist 100 kg schwer?
Ich vergesse manchmal, der ist schon ganz...
Ah, nix.
Was ist ein kleines Fehler? Ist nicht schlimm.
Er stammt sich bei uns heute wegen, seit 4 Tagen, bestehender, abdominal Schmerz.
Vorstärkenschmerzen?
Vor. Die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen in Science States liegt auf einer Skalaakt von Sain.
Und die Schmerzen sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzcharakteristik ist stehend.
Und es gibt ein Period, sie wissen, 1 und 10 Minuten.
Eine Periode zwischen 1 und 10 Minuten bedeutet, dass es jeweils alle 1 Minute oder alle 10 Minuten kommt der Schmerz.
Die Schmerzen halten 1 bis 10 Minuten an.
Periode bedeutet, dass es immer zwischen 1 und 10 Minuten wieder kommt.
Das stimmt ja nicht, das habe ich ja nicht gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, es hält an 1 Minute bis 10 Minuten.
Darf ich dauerhaft noch?
Klar, auf jeden Fall.
Die Schmerzen dauern 1 bis 10 Minuten.
Ja, gut.
Und der Patient berichtete, dass die Heißbaden geholfen hat.
Entschuldigung, oder Heißes Baden geht auch?
Baden, entweder Heißes Baden oder Heißes Baden geht beides, ist egal.
Wie Schmerzstrahlen unterkostal bereichen und auch rückern bereichen?
Nicht interkostal bereichen, das stimmt nicht.
Interkostal bereichen bedeutet, dass die Schmerzen zwischen den Rippen sind.
Ich habe keine Interkostalschmerzen.
Ich habe unteran gesagt, aber ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich nicht mehr bereiche.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich nicht mehr bereiche.
Die Schmerzen sind am besten im Oberbauch, unterhalb der Rippenbögen.
Darf ich wiederholen?
Natürlich.
Die Schmerzenstrahlen unter Rippen bereichen und auch rückern bereichen.
Ich würde ehrlich gesagt unter Rippen gar nicht erwähnen.
Die Schmerzen beginnen im Oberbauch, das ist auch Epigastrium.
Im Oberbauch Epigastrium beginnen die Schmerzen und strahlen in den Rücken aus, das reicht.
Unterhalb der Rippen, das hat der Patient gesagt, das muss man nicht aufhören.
Wichtig ist, der Patient hat Oberbauchschmerzen und die Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken aus.
Den Rest muss man nicht sagen.
Noch mal wiederholen, bitte.
Der Patient hat wo die Schmerzen?
Der Patient gab an das die Schmerzen.
Im Hypokonträtberg.
Bitte, was?
Ich konnte dieses Satz nicht bauen.
Entschuldigen Sie.
Dass die Schmerzen im Oberbauch beginnen und in den Rücken ausstrahlen, das ist doch ein einfacher Satz.
Der Patient berichtet, dass die Schmerzen im Oberbauch beginnen, Epigastrium.
Oder Oberbauch sei egal und in den Rücken ausstrahlen.
Noch mal, wir machen den Satz, wie ist der Satz Perfekt, das nochmals an vorne.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken und Epigastrikbereich aus.
Nein, die schralen nicht in den Epigastrium aus.
Die Schmerzen beginnen im Epigastrium.
Epigastrium ist ein Schmerz, der sich in den Rücken ausstrahlt.
Epigastrium ist genau die Mitte oben zwischen beiden Rippenbogen, genau die Mitte vom Bauch oben Oberbauch.
Die Schmerzen beginnen im Oberbauch, vergessen Sie Epigastrium.
Die Schmerzen beginnen im Oberbauch und strahlen in den Rücken aus.
Oberbauch der Baschliur, Strythavoudiur.
Okay, noch mal, noch mal, falsch.
Die Schmerzen beginnen im Oberbauch und strahlen in den Rücken aus.
Perfekt, jetzt haben wir es, genau. Okay, weiter.
Danke, es gibt keine bestimmte Auslöser.
Die sind nicht abhängig von Essen oder...
Sicher nicht, sicher nicht abhängig vom Essen.
Sie haben das gesagt, deswegen...
Er hat letztens Trauben gegessen und danach hat er Beschwerden gekriegt, hat er gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, er weiß nicht genau, ob das Mahlzeiten abhängig ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich, so wie er das Patient, die Patienten sagen immer falsche Sachen.
Aber wenn er sagt, er hat etwas gegessen und danach haben die Beschwerden begonnen,
dann muss man schon davon ausgehen, dass das Mahlzeiten abhängig ist.
Und letztens eben hat doch einer gefragt aus der Runde, hat doch gesagt,
ob die Beschwerden Mahlzeiten abhängig sind und dann hat dieser Patient auch gesagt,
er hat etwas gegessen und eine halbe bis dreiviertel Stunde später hat er Beschwerden gehabt.
Oder, habe ich gesagt, ne?
Ja, nachdem die, an einem Nestgespräch, sie haben das gesagt,
aber meine Frage war so deutlich, ich habe jetzt gefragt,
gibt es ein bestimmtes...
Also er hat...
Aber die Runde hat ja nochmal gefragt und dann hat er nochmal...
die expliziten nochmal gefragt und dann hat er nochmal...
Normalerweise habe ich diese Information nicht, deswegen ich möchte nicht, dass er wehnen.
Okay, alles klar, dann erwähnt ihr es.
Okay, ne.
Welche zu einem Nest unaufwählige bis auf Schlafstürzmüll,
und für Erkrankungen, wie diese keine, für Erkrankungen,
nehmen sie keine...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, stopp nicht die.
Ja, genau, nehmen er keine mit Kommentar.
Sie wurden nie operiert.
Er sei allergie gegen Penicillin.
Allergie gegen Penicillin.
Und die allergie äußert sich mit...
Was war das?
Haut auf Schlaf und Halsschwellung.
Haut auf Schlaf, was ist das?
Exantium kann man auch sagen, ja, exantium und Halsschwellung.
Und Halsschwellung.
Halsschwellung, Halsschwellung, Halsschwellung, kann man beides sagen.
Was will denn?
Aber es ist besser, wenn man Halsschwellung sagt.
Irgendwie sagen die Deutschen, also wir immer Halsschwellung.
Er trinke einmal pro Monat mit Iran.
Seinen.
Mit seinen.
Ersten Junge, ne? Ersten Herr, Anmann, mit seinen.
Seinen Freunden.
Ein bis drei Flasche Bier.
Und Drogen abiusen, wo der Feier neint.
Und in der Familie haben wir nur am Vater Hypertonie und Adipos.
Noch mal. Das geht so nicht so, nicht züchstelend übersetzen.
Ja, bitte noch einmal bitte.
Okay.
Der Vater des Patienten ist in Haup, habe Hypertonie und er ist Adipos.
Sehr gut. Der Vater des Patienten hat eine Atelierli, der Vater des Patienten hat eine Atelierli Hypertonie und ist Adipös.
Sehr gut, ja. Und die Mutter?
Und seine Mutter sei gesund.
Sehr gut, ja.
Er ist verheiratet, er hat vier Kinder.
Stress auf der Arbeit wurde verneint.
Er war nicht im Ausland in der letzten Zeit.
Und er ist voll geämpft.
Super, sehr gut, ja.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ein Moment.
Ich möchte eine Zusammenfassung machen, Herr Junge.
Wieso? Er soll die Zusammenfassung machen.
Ein Minute.
Eine Minute, okay.
Herr Sacki ist 30 Jahre alt, 1,80 kg und 100 kg schwer.
Herr Sacki hat sich bei uns seit vier Tagen akut aufgetretener, wellenförmiger, abdominaler Schmerzattacken im Ganzenbau vorgestattet.
Nicht im Ganzenbau, das stimmt nicht, im Oberbauch.
Ein Diffus, aber Sie haben Diffus.
Auslärdenbechirbe erdischenmerzen, als ich täglich enthielt und Diffus.
Abdominaler Schmerzen bedroht.
Nein, ich habe nicht Diffus, aber du nennst es nicht.
Meine Schmerzen sind nur im Oberbauch.
Hab ich die ganze Zeit gesagt.
Okay. Auslärdenbechirbe erdischenmerzen, als ich täglich enthielt und Diffus.
Des weiteren Haberdischenmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10,
bei acht Mitstrahlung in den Rücken eingechest.
Mit Ausstrahlung in den Rücken.
Mit Ausstrahlung.
Herr Nezayen, den Patienten in den letzten zwei Tagen folgenden Begleitsymptome aufgefallen,
hellen Stül und dunkel üren.
Dunkel in Urin hat er nicht nackt.
Er hat nur hellen Stuhl gehabt, einmal. Aber kein dunkel in Urin.
Auf gezündeten Nachfragen berichtete er, dass er keine Neusea,
Emesis, Fiba, Icterus hatte.
Die Fragen nach erleichtern oder Verschlimmenden Faktoren und bestimmte Auslöse wurden verneint.
Punkt.
Bitte schön, Seifet.
Hallo?
Ja.
Meine Verdachteragnose ist Colitis.
Oder Colistitis.
Und aus differenzialen Diagnose kommen Castritis oder Nephrolitis.
Was kommt als allererstes in Frage, wenn er Oberbauchschmerzen hat,
die in den Rücken ausstrahlen?
Sie haben alle nicht gefragt, ob die Gürtelförmig ausstrahlen.
Keiner von Ihnen hat gefragt, ob die Schmerzen, die der Patient hat,
Gürtelförmig nach hinten ausstrahlen.
Und ich sage Ihnen das jetzt.
Der Patient hat Gürtelförmig ausstrahlende Schmerzen in den Rücken.
Das hat keiner von Ihnen gefragt.
Das ist einer der wichtigsten Fragen, die dazu gelandet.
Warum?
Was ist in der Regel so, was macht Schmerzen,
die Gürtelförmig auf den Rücken ausstrahlen?
Welche Erkrankungen?
Wir haben kurz Panthritis.
Richtig, genau.
Mit den Panthritis, dann hätte man schon fragen sollen,
ob die Gürtelförmig ausstrahlen oder nicht.
Aber hat ja nichts zu sagen.
Es muss ja keine Panthritis sagen.
Aber die Differenzialdiagnose muss man dran denken immer.
Was noch, was kann noch sein, wenn der Patient Oberbauchschmerzen hat?
Was wird oft, oft, oft eine schwere Erkrankung,
wird immer übersehen bei Oberbauchschmerzen?
Das wissen Sie aber alle.
Welches Organ ist da noch in der Wehe?
Wir haben Leber und...
Immer nach oben, nicht nach unten immer, nach oben.
Was ist oben noch für ein Organ?
Wir haben Herzvideos.
Ja, genau.
Welche Herzerkrankungen macht Oberbauchschmerzen?
Erst gibt es eine Verstopfung im Zirkoflexalter.
In dieser Frage könnte es sein.
Was ist das? Was macht das?
Was bedeutet Verstopfung im Zirkoflexalter?
Oder der RCR?
Was macht das?
Man geht best ein Trumpfes?
Was ist das?
Wie nennt man das?
Ein Hinkeirwand infargt.
Sagen Sie einfach mal Hinkeirwand infargt.
Keiner will wissen, ob es der RCA ist.
Ein Hinkeirwand infargt, macht genau dieselben Beschwerden.
Es wird oft überwählen.
Nicht erzählen, es ist zirk. Lexus RCA.
Das interessiert keinen.
Hinkeirwand infargt, macht typisch Oberbauchschmerz.
Es wird oft überwählen.
Ja?
Genau.
Super.
Was muss?
Es könnte sein, dass es ein Hippatopatien kann.
Auch Leberprobleme können das machen.
Aber die wichtigsten haben Sie schon gesagt.
Das drittes kann es machen.
Hinkeirwand infargt nicht vergessen.
Dann haben Sie gesagt, Nieren kann es machen.
Das drittes, Sie haben die wichtigsten Sachen schon gesagt.
Manchmal kann man das auch sagen.
Man kann die Abdominaler-Orter auch mal so etwas machen.
Man muss immer alles segeln.
Aber sonst war das sonst sehr gut.
Man muss die Diagnose und Labur machen.
Dann sind Sie fertig.
Ich wollte erst eine Routine,
eine Biochemische, testen.
Zum Beispiel Ulkos.
Und Acetylalytilage.
Was wollten Sie machen?
Entschuldigung, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wie kann ich sagen?
Die Leber-Werte.
Leber-Funktionswerte.
Nehmen Funktionswerte.
Was noch?
Elektrolyten.
Ich möchte noch etwas von den Leber-Werten.
Die Transaminase.
Was noch?
Transaminase, Leber-Libase.
Das ist wichtig.
Die Patientin hat ja auch Schmerzen.
Transaminase, Bilirubin.
Warum Bilirubin?
Amargetil machen wir sowieso mit.
Perrp natürlich Entzündungswerte, Leukozytengrande zu.
Die Leber-Werte, Grinnungswerte, Leber machen wir noch mit.
Den Au-Orter.
Das ist wichtig.
Die Sektion ist,
würde ich die Leber-Werte mitmachen.
Das troponieren.
Was machen Sie an Apparativer Diagnostik?
Ich würde Eco-Dofüren.
Das würde ich kombinieren.
Sehr gut.
Das ist wichtig.
Ich würde auch das Eco-Dofüren auch mitmachen.
Ich würde auch das Eco-Dofüren mitmachen.
Ich würde das Eco-Dofüren mitmachen.
Das ist wichtig.
Wenn Sie da einen Gallenstau sehen,
erweiterte Gallengänge.
Oder einen verdickten Gallenblasenwand,
Aber Gallenblase kann man ja sehr gut beurteilen und das Herz kann man ja auch gut beurteilen.
Wenn er Wasser in der Gallenblase hat, Slutsch oder Stein oder Gallen, Gangerweiterung oder
Gallenblasenwandverdickung, das sind ja so die Zeichen.
Und ich sage Ihnen etwas, das ist eine wahre Geschichte jetzt.
Ach so, und wenn er etwas hat, wenn er jetzt da ein Stein hat, die Gallengänge sind
erweitert und das Bilirubin bei 10 ist, die Transaminasen stark erhöht sind,
er hat ein CHP. Was macht man dann?
Ich würde die Patientinstation aufnahmen, dann wenn wir so lange liegen und also eine Nahrung
verordnen und danach würde ich ein syrisches Konzil verordnen, anordnen, oder?
Aber das müssen Sie ja jetzt sagen, wir sind der Arzt jetzt, also in der
Facharztprüfung müssen Sie ja jetzt alles selber sagen, genau, Chirox-Konzil,
aber Sie müssen, was machen Sie, was ist die Therapie, wenn der Patient da ein Stau hat,
wenn man das bemutet und er hat tatsächlich auch, ich sage Ihnen, das war ein wahrer Fall,
wirklich ein 30-jähriger Notarztfahrer, das ist mein Notarztfahrer.
Letztens mal, als ich Notarztdienst gewesen bin, als ich Notärztin und erfährte immer mit dem
Notarztwagen, hat er gesagt, er hat jetzt ganz starke Oberbauchschmerzen, habe ich gesagt,
naja, es geht schon weg, ich hatte ihm Weintrauben geschenkt, ich habe Weintrauben gekauft,
dann hat er die gegessen und eine Stunde später hat er dann dieser super stark Schmerzen gehabt,
er hat gesagt vor vier Tagen hat er dieselben Schmerzen, hat einen Bart genommen, dann war es weg.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, Max, das geht so nicht, wir gehen jetzt sofort in den Notaufnahme,
wir haben sowieso Patienten gebracht, ich habe gesagt, du gehst jetzt in den Notaufnahmen und
lässt dich untersuchen. Dann habe ich gesagt, sag mal bitte den Chironen Bescheid zu den
Schwestern, da soll mal einer kommen, meinem Nefffahrer geht es nicht gut. Und dann haben wir
den hingelegt, also alles ganz normal, was man immer macht, Zugang gelegt, Schmerzmittel gegeben
und ich weiß gar nicht, was wir gegeben haben, nur weil gehen irgendwas noch dazu, irgendwann hat
das nicht gekämpfen, dann haben wir Dipidolore noch dazu gegeben, der Chiron kam, hat
einen Ultraschall gemacht, er hat gesagt, er sieht keine Dreischichtung der geilen Blasenwand,
das ist ja die Entzündungszeichen, die man sieht, die Dreischichtung der geilen Blasenwand sieht
er nicht, er hat gesagt, er sieht nur ein bisschen Flutsch in der geilen Blase und was ich nicht
gesehen habe, was dann die Chironen doch noch mal als die Tiefe in die Augen geguckt haben,
hallo, ich gucke jetzt den Männern nicht so tief in die Augen rein, also die haben dann
gesehen, dass er geldliche Augen wohl auch hatte, er hatte wohl auch einen Sklärenikterus,
sagt man dazu, das ist ein Leerenikterus und dann haben sie ihn natürlich, er hat kein Fieber
gehabt und dann habe ich ihn gefragt, bevor ich gesagt habe, er muss nur, habe ich gesagt Matze,
hast du irgendwann mal die einfachste schnelle Diagnose ist, wer man vermutet,
geilen Blase, hast du irgendwann mal, habe ich gesagt, einen Stuhlgang gehabt,
der sehr hell war, nicht mehr braun war, hat er gesagt, ja vor vier Tagen,
habe ich gesagt, wart er Urin mal dunkler als normal, so richtig dunkel, hat er gesagt, nein,
aber dass die Schmerzen nach der Mahlzeit aufgetreten sind, ja und dieser entfärbte
Stuhlgang, der spricht er schon dafür, letztendlich war die Diagnose, Bilirubin war sehr hoch, er
ist auf Station aufgenommen worden und die Diagnose war letztendlich Steinabgang, er hat vor vier
Tagen wahrscheinlich ein Steinabgang und deswegen hatte er jetzt noch diese Schweren gehabt,
er ist eine Nacht da geblieben und weil die Werte abgefallen sind, ist er dann wieder nach
Ok, aber ich muss jetzt mal etwas sagen, jetzt mal, wenn sie wollen können sie jetzt stoppen,
stoppen, habt ihr das Michelle?